Salam alaikum guys how you doing I'm
with Simon Simon how are you doing I'm
fine thanks al hamdulillah so so the
news is that you just accepted Islam how
long ago 2 years in March can you tell
us what was so amazing about Islam
you're you're a Brit they called Britain
yeah from British I mean from from
Britain and you know with all of the
hype and all of the misconceptions and
all that he took a bold step yeah you
accepted Islam what was it that amazed
you about Islam that had you accepted
well my stepson my wife son he
introduced me to it to start with so
what kind of a person he was and it's
hard to say really because I'm trying to
I'm trying to when I when I first when I
become a mad woman I became a Muslim
after to talk Misha harder and I started
practicing it and reading the Quran I
realized what I was getting into and
it's nothing like what I expected it to
be I was brought up as a Christian and
my belief scene about Christianity and
that kind of thing don't
I can't align with them but yeah when I
read the Quran it was so simple so
straightforward there's nothing in it
that I could see to dispute whereas the
Bible there's a lot of things in it
which are open to interpretation that
etc the Roman connection you know the
Jesus was like portrayed as a miracle
worker where I think it was
sensationalized a bit perhaps in
Christianity which takes the air the the
honors away from what it's actually
about but as I say Islam to me is a pure
pure religion pure faith when I was
immersed in this summer I used to do
that dowel with Osman I wanted to it was
like I'd won the lottery
it was like I'd won something and I
wanted to spread the word and tell
people when you hear about born-again
Christians you know you think they do
you think were born again Christians did
a big big race but I was doing the same
thing I couldn't believe what I was
doing what I was feeling and what I
wanted to portray to people so hungy
alarmed I'm so glad I became a Muslim
and I've never been particularly
religious before
you know I always kind of believed in
the Darwin theory that kind of thing but
this about my mind my mind of reason
it's a one time people believe that
science was in one and religion were
opposed to each other but now if you
read in the Quran you can see that they
actually come together it's all that
Darwin thing I don't I'm totally
believing God now and I don't think
about the Darwin figure if you like that
because these powers been explained to
make food in the Quran and speaking to
other people as well the Muslims what
advice would you have for other Brits
other people out there who their minds
are really having the ideas that Islam
is something that is foreign Islam is
something of the other that Islam is
something violent and the list goes on
of all of these things that contradict
Islam I would advice would you have for
them I would say you've got to look
beyond that you've got to really focus
on what it will what actually Islam
actually is or know what you've been
told it is what you your conceptions of
it are misconceptions you've got have
got look past that read the Quran speak
to all the Muslims come to a Musk pray
feel what I felt
yeah and inshallah that's you know
you'll get the same benefit from it that
I got God willing you will that's right
inshallah it's because you want to know
the how why and where how'd you end up
here why are you here where are you
going
he's figured it all he's living the
purpose of life he got through all the
hype you know he's a Muslim one who has
submitted his will to the Creator that
happens at earth he gave you some great
advice read the Quran read it pick up
the book and read it make the human
connection meet a Muslim thank you so
much for sharing that with us and thank
you guys peace be with you so don't wake
them from UK